and I'm just really pleased to be here
as an aide said I
here at Sierra
and really had a great experience
working with Nate and other
investigators here and i still have
really important collaborations with the
investigators here including nate so
it's been a great experience for me and
a great launching point for my career
and as nate told you i had a small
development or pilot grant as a part of
my fellowship that actually allowed me
to get the grant that i'm the grant that
i will discuss findings from today not
so much related to the specific pilot i
did which i still do that type of
research which is of looking at daily
diaries but focused on some of the other
data that I collected through this this
project so the title of the talk that
I'd like to give today is trauma
resilience and HIV vulnerability among
young black men who have sex with men
and what I'll do is first tell you a
little bit about myself and the work I
do I like to sometimes just give a
little background that I hope give some
context to why I look at what I look at
and sort of my organizing frameworks
that sort of guide the work that I'm
doing so I am broadly interested in the
intersecting roles that psychological
factors and social contextual factors
play in explaining HIV risk and
vulnerability among ethnic minority men
who have sex with men or msn the acronym
you'll hear me use a lot during this
talk I'm also interested in situational
factors that promoter prevent sexual
risk-taking behavior substance use for
mental health and engagement and care
among MSM and have been doing a lot of
work in the last five to seven years on
interventions and specifically the
development implementation and
evaluation of secondary prevention
interventions primarily focused on HIV
positive MSM as well as adolescent
populations so when I am gave actually
my first job talk I use this model
and I still go back to it it's still
useful heuristic for me in terms of just
the broad framework that again organizes
a lot of my ideas and so the work I do
and it's really i'm interested in
context process and outcome most of my
outcomes are health focused whether it
be HIV or mental health which puts me in
a school of public health but i'm also
interested in to the psychological
processes that connect social contextual
factors to the health outcomes that i'm
interested in and that we look at within
psychology and public health so
contextual factors include communities
that we belong to I've done a lot of
work looking at religious institutions
some of what I'll talk to you about
today has to do with traumatic life
experiences and through the diary work
that I do I look at sexual situations
and some of the more psychological
variables that I'm interested in
understanding particularly as as
mediators or moderators of the
relationship between context and outcome
are things like individual and
collective efficacy self-regulation
resilience something that I'll talk to
you about today that I also feel like is
a somewhat problematic construct in a
good way but still nonetheless
problematic and psychological distress
and the outcomes I'm most interested in
of course have to do with HIV so condom
use substance use but also for people
living with HIV engagement and care and
more specifically adherence to
antiretroviral medications which are
increasingly important not just for the
treatment of disease but also the
prevention of transmission to uninfected
others so before I talk to you about the
specifics to my study and the project
that I did over the last couple of years
I wanted to just give a broad overview
of some of the epidemiological data for
HIV among black men have sex with men
here in the United States and I know a
lot of you will be aware of some of this
stuff and some of you may not but I like
to just provide some type of
context to why this is important why
look at HIV for black men who have sex
with men and I really like this piece by
one of my colleagues actually at
Columbia wafaa al-sadr and her
colleagues published in the New England
Journal of Medicine in 2010 this really
interesting article that sort of
compared HIV prevalence and incidence in
sub-saharan Africa with incidence and
prevalence rates here in United States
but really focusing on specific
subpopulations and areas of the country
and those of you who know wafaa know
that she directs I capped international
center for age prevention studies at
Columbia and it's mostly global work
that she's doing but this was a piece
that she titled those sort of believe
it's the lost and forgotten epidemic as
a way to sort of highlight what's
happening in our own backyard and it's
something that I like to do because I do
most of my work domestically and the
reason I do that is because we still do
have major problems when it comes to HIV
and of course other public health issues
in this country but this this graph is
really nice because again we're
comparing or she's comparing here cities
and subpopulations in the united states
with prevalence rates for countries in
sub-saharan africa where a lot of our
research efforts are going toward it
rightfully so don't don't get me wrong
but you can see that depending on the
subgroup for example black men in
washington DC you have prevalence rates
that rival if not surpass places like
Nigeria when you look at men who have
sex with men in New York City you're
getting two prevalence rates that are
beyond kenya and rivaling are getting
close to south africa places where we
see generalized epidemics where we know
that there's massive intervention needed
to reduce the impact of the epidemic on
the population this little map you can
see is of New York City that's where I
do research and another area that I
think is important for us to remember
has a very
impactful epidemic particularly
impactful on msn but you can see in
certain areas of New York City like
lower Manhattan where the West Village
in Chelsea so the gay ghettos are but
also areas where you have predominantly
afro-caribbean african-american
populations like central Brooklyn a lot
of dominican and afro Caribbean
populations in the South Bronx where you
have again these extremely high
prevalence rates that almost look like a
generalized epidemic so we still have a
big problem in this city in this country
and these statistics really help show
that what has been a really I think
depressing message are not so much a
message but a depressive set of findings
that we've seen over the past decade
have to do with the HIV epidemic
particularly as it affects young MSM of
color and specifically young black MSM
so as you can see from these bullets
young MSM account for over a quarter of
new infections between 2006 and 2009
which is the period that we have the
most recent data for and we saw a
forty-eight percent increase among HIV
for black MSM 13 to 29 years old that's
the highest among all subgroups looked
at and again this most recent incidents
data that we have from CDC and what that
instance report that prejean and
colleagues published in 2011 showed us
was that we really had a stable epidemic
except for young MSM of color that's
where we saw increasing rates of
infection and it's not really an alarm
call you could say because the alarms
been going off for years now and that's
what we don't always remember there has
been a little bit more increased focus
on understanding what's happening for
black people in the United States
becomes HIV and even some focus even on
MSM of color but we know from
seroprevalence data dating back to 2,000
one
a young black MSM have been
disproportionately impacted by HIV so it
really to me has been a he to action
that really requires us to start to do
more dedicated focused interventions to
help reduce the impact of HIV on young
black MSM so I won't continue to just
harp on this but you can see again from
2001 to 2005 looking at age 13 to 24
young men who have sex with men the
black Hispanic group has extremely well
a high rate of increase relative to the
other groups and then going to our most
recent data that we have or the most
recent period we have data for two
thousand six to two thousand nine again
increasing so this the story has been
consistent over these last several years
why are these disparities taking place
why are young MSM of color more impacted
by HIV than other groups it must be
because they have more unprotected sex
that's you know the simple explanation
but it's also the incorrect explanation
and I'm sure some of you if you're
interested in this population or HIV and
domestically you may have heard of a guy
named Greg mullet he's in a lot of
meta-analyses and he's focused a lot of
that work on understanding the
disparities among MSM when it comes to
HIV infection and I had the the
privilege to work with him on a
meta-analysis that we published last
year right and sort of at the time of
the International AIDS Conference which
many of you know was held here United
States for the first time in many many
years in Washington DC and in this
meta-analysis he really confirms what
he's been finding for years doing these
types of analyses which is that it's not
about sexual risk behavior it's not
about unprotected sex it's about other
factors that
shape and sort of create enhanced
vulnerability for black men who have sex
with men so I realized this is a really
tiny difficult to read table so I'm
going to just try to briefly show you a
little bit of what he's what he did here
so he has a set of different factors
that he looked at and wanted to look at
the odds of the probability that this
impacted black men have sex with men
more than other men have sex at midnight
that comparing really white MSM and what
I've highlighted here are the factors
that have an odds ratio above one that
there was a significant difference and
you can see the the top risk factor for
black MSM was having black partners it's
sort of weird to say having a same race
partner as a risk factor but when you
have such a high prevalence the risk
becomes greater of course if you're
having partners where the who come from
a pool where there's a greater
likelihood of being infected having a
current STI diagnosis another important
risk factor we know that if you have an
STI particularly undiagnosed as together
it's not treated you're high you're much
more susceptible to not only
transmitting HIV HIV positive but
receiving HIV if you're negative
undiagnosed HIV another big issue for
black MSM something that I think gets
more at structural issues or you could
say individual level factors but I like
to think of it more in the structural
perspective and that's low education
things like cd4 counts that are low low
income crack cocaine use all of these
factors you know are about I think they
tell a really complex story that goes
from things like individual level
behaviors and factors to more structural
conditions like access to care like a
poverty etc so there
is a not an easy story to tell when it
comes to why black MSM are more likely
to become HIV positive than other groups
but we know it's not all about just
their individual level risk I won't go
into as great a detail but again this is
us looking at differences among HIV
positive versus other it or HIV positive
black MSM vs HIV positive MSM of other
races and ethnicities and you can see
where the differences are in disclosure
that has a lot to do with stigma another
really important issue that has to be
addressed in this population access to
HIV care substance use in this case it's
primarily crack cocaine and also the
structural barriers of income and
education so I hope you get a good idea
now of that there is a problem first of
all and that the sort of reasons behind
the problem are complicated they're not
necessarily all related to individual
level behaviors and risk factors it's a
lot of different things going on that
are shaping risk and I was really
interested largely because of work that
i did with nate and kathy sakuma who
used to be here and our colleagues
focused on traumatic experiences
particularly childhood sexual abuse
among people living with HIV I really
got an interest in trauma and what I
really like to call more generally
chaotic life experiences I'm not
necessarily looking at PTSD diagnosis in
terms of how I operationalize what a
traumatic experience may be but it is
more about conditions that are
particularly stressful and how that
shapes different outcomes for MSM of
color so traumatic life experiences and
vulnerability for MSM MSM particularly
urban
no sex with men contend with
co-occurring problems that can be
described as ass endemic this is another
conceptual framework that I really like
that you know really evolved out of work
originally done by I know a very good
friend of sear and collaborator Meryl
singer and I think it's a really nice
way to think about how multiple
epidemics shape outcomes so Meryl sing
it well I'll get to him in a second but
in thinking about the sort of multiple
epidemics that shape health outcomes for
young black MSM there's data that
suggests and most of this is qualitative
data that black MSM are subject to
numerous traumatic life experiences that
can enhance vulnerability to HIV that
includes things like childhood sexual
abuse but also exposure to to truly
abject poverty not just you know living
in a low-income housing but not
necessarily having a place to have to
get food not necessarily knowing that
you're going to have shelves or
homelessness a big factor as well as
incarceration xand experiences with
juvenile justice system so i use this
idea of sin demic as a framework because
it does sort of help us understand how
both social and physiological epidemics
cluster together and you can have things
like chronic infectious diseases that
co-occur with racism and institutional
poverty so an epidemic isn't just about
a health outcome but it really is about
a health outcome by a certain person
place and time it really is
contextualizing and integrating health
and social conditions in a way that I
think really works so this is actually
in that white box coming from Merrill
singer he says sin Demyx occur when
health-related problems clustered by
person place or time the problems along
with the reasons for the clustering
define is endemic and
frenchy ate one from another although
they may have nested or overlapping
relationships to prevent us endemic one
must not only prevent or control each
disease but also the forces that tie
those diseases together and that I think
is a crux of his argument and a really
important piece to think about is it's
not just about intervening upon the one
condition or one disease but really
thinking about those social forces that
bind those conditions or diseases so
with that I was interested in thinking
about various experiences that young
black MSM have and trying to understand
the additive impacts of those
experiences on their health outcomes and
to do this I used data from a study
conducted between really 2009 and 2011
we finished it early 2012 that was
called the brothers connect studying it
involved three nested data collection
strategies of the first was a
cross-sectional survey that we did the
goal was 250 but we got to 227 to
internet survive and young black
innocent and that focused on demographic
psychosocial and family peer group
information we got experiences or
information on sexual behavior substance
use behaviors and also these sort of
what I was calling distal risk factors
like exposure to poverty to substance
use discrimination other forms of trauma
and also to look at resiliency factors
which I'll get to in a little bit the
other two data collection strategies
which I'm not going to get into at this
time were a longitudinal sex diary that
150 participants who did the
cross-sectional survey completed and
that was a diary that was conducted over
eight weeks it was a weekly diary it's a
basically a survey called a diary but
it's not you know sort of the the
qualitative dear diary I had a great day
to day it's more about doing a regular
survey
that assesses sort of your feelings at a
given moment and here we did a diary
that asks participants to record how
they were feeling but also to record
their instances of having sexual
behavior and then to tell us details
about one of those episodes in the prior
week we next then did in-depth
interviews with a subsample of 30
participants who had done both the
cross-sectional survey and the sex diary
and we're still in the process of
analyzing the qualitative data I started
to look at our lodged in the sex diary
data and I would love to be able to talk
to you guys about that next time if you
want to bring me back so the sample is a
convenient sample very much a
community-based sample we aim to be as
diverse as possible and our recruitment
been used but you can see a good third
of the sample did come from a sort of
snowballing or participant referrals we
we had a maximum of two referrals per
participant but it was an important
strategy for us to get to our numbers we
actually had a very short period of time
in which we had to do this that we had
one year because of lots of delays from
CDC in terms of allowing us to get our
get started we also did outreach at
community-based organizations and clubs
were about a quarter of our sample came
from and then also online venues like
black gay chat which is a popular online
hookup website as well as Facebook and
other related sort of social media
websites and then of course just through
firing so again I apologize for the
slightly tiny text here but these are
the characteristics of the sample it's
not the biggest of samples but for this
population there haven't been that many
studies on where you've gotten a good
number like more than 200 of a young
buck and I said unless you're talking
about a large-scale CDC funded study so
I was really proud of X being able to
get these numbers it's a race or i
should say ethnically diverse sample
all of our participants identified
essentially as black but you could see
while most were 61 percent African
American or black we also had a sort of
black hispanic or afro-caribbean
participants that were twenty eight
percent and seven percent and then also
mixed race participants for education we
have this paradox that I see it a lot of
my samples actually and not just my
samples with the sample of my colleagues
in New York where you see a relatively
high levels of education but but also
low income levels so there's this
disparity of education and income and we
have that in this sample as wearable as
well with you know almost two-thirds of
sample having at least some college but
most you know seventy-four percent
having an income of 25,000 a year or
sorry 20,000 a year or less and a lot of
that has to do with that a quarter of
these students a quarter of these
participants were students but also you
can see thirty-five percent were
unemployed of course we are in a
hopefully upswing in our economy but
things are still hard and they certainly
were between 2009-2011 so some of this
is a function of just where we are in
terms of the economy in the city and
then in the country you can see either
of their insurance status most of these
participants most of these guys had
tested for HIV 83% out of the those who
are HIV negative had tested for HIV in
the last six months about a quarter were
HIV positive on which is you know not
surprising at all given you know the
epidemiology that we just saw also 75%
identified as gay of where is twenty-six
percent bisexual we also asked just
really out of curiosity how they would
label themselves with these other sort
of designations of including same gender
loving two-spirited queer homothug and
on the down low and you can see that
same gender loving was most popular
endorsed but the other categories were
also endorsed most were single a good
proportion 6459 percent had had
unprotected anal intercourse or uai in
the past two months thirteen percent
reported Cyril discordant uai and for
drug use the majority reported some drug
use most of that being marijuana but we
also had about thirty percent who
reported a stimulant use either coke
crack or methamphetamine so for this to
the part of the the project I wanted to
understand well first traumatic life
experiences among young black MSM and
then get a sort of to be able to explore
the relationship of those experiences to
risk factors including unprotected
intercourse substance use and depression
and what I really was interested in is
actually replicating some of the work of
a colleague in front of mine Ron stall
who looked at additive effects of sort
of traumatic life experiences on HIV
vulnerability for a large sample of
multi-ethnic MSM and he was using also
this Swiss endemics framework to sort of
think through his his findings so first
you can see here these are just odds
ratios looking at the relationship
between our sort of five categories of
traumatic life experiences physical
abuse sexual abuse sex work homelessness
and incarcerations with the outcomes
that I was most interested in
unprotected intercourse and Sarah
discordant or uai as well as a cage
which is a measure of alcohol abuse drug
use and stimulant yeast and then also
major depression which we looked at
using the k10 which is a very popularly
used measure and you can see it I won't
go through everything but you can see
that their relationships across the
different traumatic life experience
variables and HIV risk factors for those
who experience physical abuse you can
see a greater likelihood of having uai a
great likelihood of alcohol abuse
stimulant use as well as major
depression for sexual abuse primarily
you a I was where the main finding was
and i should say these are at the p.o
point 10 level of significance is why
you are seeing for some of the
confidence intervals one is included
like for this one so this is not all you
know robust significance but I'd like to
use comp intervals as opposed to
p-values just to give you a better idea
of like what's actually happening here
and you again you see some relationships
here on bigger ones with sex work and
stimulant use for homelessness we see
relationships with discord in uai drug
use and so on so a consolation of
relationships here but the pattern I
think so it shows some kind of you could
almost say convergent validity in the
sense that each of these again traumatic
life experiences is related to some type
of vulnerability or risk outcome so when
it came to looking at the number of a
traumatic events or life experiences
experienced more than a quarter of the
sample twenty-seven percent of
experience none so didn't experience any
physical abuse sexual abuse homelessness
incarceration or sex work but about a
twenty percent our fifth had experienced
one another twenty percent or twenty one
percent really experienced two and
almost a third had experienced three or
more of those traumatic life experiences
and so when I looked at just the raw
means or these are frequencies for the
different outcomes you did start to see
somewhat of a linear effect here such
that you can see for those with no
traumatic life experiences you had about
thirty nine percent reporting you a I in
the past two months with one it jumped
to fifty nine percent to sixty-six
percent three sixty eight percent when I
did generalized linear models that sort
of helped me see how these odds change
with increasing traumatic life
experiences you can see when setting you
know no none as are basically a
comparison so no odds relative to having
no odds or to having no traumatic life
experience you have about a 2.21
increased odds if you have one moving up
to 3.2 92 and then we see a little dip
but it's really about the same as the
the two there which is as this red line
shows us a pretty strong linear trend
that you're seeing there as you see
increasing traumatic life experiences
you see increasing odds for unprotected
intercourse we didn't have as much of
variation and co does Courtney why I
because most were participants
participants had not had discordant uai
but you still see this linear although
it's when you look at those odds ratios
it does seem you know like you have a
more like a quadratic happening there
but you can see that again increased
odds as exposures go up with having two
exposures being of quite high relative
to the others however this sorry I was
just at marginally significant this this
finding the generalized linear model
look at stimulant use or use of cocaine
crack or methamphetamine again the raw
frequencies show somewhat of a linear
trend and then when you look at those
odds ratios with increasing exposures
again you have this this pretty strong
impact of traumatic life experiences on
stimulant youth and then finally I don't
have the fancy line graph because these
are the actual estimated marginal means
from that generalized linear model which
show it doesn't you know look maybe as
striking as the odds ratios but this is
sorry the strongest effect that I see
when you look at these these increasing
exposures the the impact on the
depression measure using the k10 is
pretty strong with none having about
score 14 2 going up to about a score 21
for those with of three exposures so
what we saw was that there was this
additive effect of trauma experiences on
HIV risk factors and that really showed
us that increasing numbers of these
exposures to traumatic life events
increase the odds of engaging in the
unprotected sex increased the odds of
substance use as well as increased
depression but there does seem like
there could be somewhat of a ceiling
effect that once you have perhaps more
than two exposures you may not see as
much increase the more you have and Ron
stall who again I modeled some of this
or whose paper I used as a framework to
model some of these analyses founded a
very similar ceiling effect in his work
so what does this tell us that young
black MSM are negatively impacted by
multiple forms of trauma and that these
experiences are not limited to just that
I shouldn't say just because childhood
sexual abuse is by itself it's a very
impactful and negative event but also
homelessness physical abuse and violence
and car serrations are also really
critical risk factors that increase
vulnerability in this population and it
does appear that there may be
physiological and sociological epidemics
interacting to increase vulnerability or
that there is thus endemic of power
of abuse and incarceration zat is going
on so if we really want to engage in in
interventions and prevention work that's
going to be high-impact as is a
catchphrase as well as this idea of
combination prevention we have to also
think about socio-cultural and
structural factors not just individual
level factors not just treatment but
also dealing with poverty thinking about
sexual silence and structural violence
and how those impact vulnerability so
I'm not done quite yet but I will be
very soon because I want to make sure I
hear your questions in fact I'm really
interested in your questions and your
input on what I'm going to present very
briefly now which is on some work that i
have really just done this it's very
preliminary you're going to be able to
tell because I having done fancy graphs
yet but that I am hoping we'll get some
traction and be able to help move some
some of the findings around resilience
out of sort of the exploration stage and
more into something that i can write up
and publish so i was interested in
understanding not just risk and
vulnerability but also resilience and
when I've had those findings looking at
the additive impact of traumatic life
experiences they were really
disheartening to me and I was looking
for moderators I was really like I mean
you're not supposed to go searching in
your data these actually were driven by
hypotheses that I had a priori but I was
looking for what were the buffers what
were things that might moderate the
impact of trauma experiences on
vulnerability and risk and I wasn't
really finding it and the assortment of
different resilience factors that I had
a operationalize and collected data on
in this and this in this study and I'll
get to that in a minute but one thing I
I didn't do is start tester to think
about resilience less as a
yoona dimensional construct and more as
something perhaps multi-dimensional so
resilience has really garnered attention
in the past a few years as a key focus
area for interventions particularly
those that are being designed and
implemented to reduce HIV and poor
mental health outcomes among men who
have sex with men and Amy Herrick and
Ron Stahl wrote a paper again to the
connecting sin demux and resilience
talking about addressing sort of
psychosocial health conditions but as
well as promoting a resilience framework
for thinking about how to best improve
outcomes in the population so they and
many others have started to think that
promoting resilience maybe the way to
actually reducing HIV approve improving
health among MSM and reducing the
negative impact of these trauma
exposures so you know taking a strength
space as opposed to deficits based
approach is again being called for and
advocated for but one thing that I've
been curious about and i know many
others as well how do you actually
operationalize resilience it actually is
not one of those very easy easily
defined concepts because it can be made
up of so many different things and just
alone for me and my conceptualization of
it I think of self-efficacy and
empowerment I think of coping skills and
things like social support and those are
some of the constructs that I measured
in the brothers connect study so as sort
of you know some exploratory aims that
have guided this these next analyses I
did was really trying to understand well
what are maybe profiles of research as
opposed to just looking at coping or
just looking at self-efficacy let's
start looking at them together and and
see how they how they group together or
what types of sort of patterns or
profiles we might see in this sample of
227 that I have and I was also stood in
looking at
some of the relationships of those
profiles to mental health outcomes so
again these are my more crude graphs
because these are more exploratory
analyses but I wanted you to see the the
main concepts I'm looking at here are
parental social support peer social
support a measure of mastery which is a
conceptualization of self-efficacy it's
a measured that was used by a
collaborator and colleague of mine Ilan
Meyer and his study of LGBT well lgb
lesbian gay bisexual individuals in New
York City and then this measure is the
Connor David Connor Davidson resiliency
scale it is a resilience measure but
it's really operation Liza's and
conceptualizes resilience in a stress
and coping framework so I think of it as
a not I won't say a proxy for stress and
coping or adaptive coping but it
certainly has items that are much more
men about coping responses than than say
sort of empowerment feelings or feelings
of confidence so I looked at those three
measures you can see there are some
significant correlations but they're all
pretty much at the lower level and when
I look at just a normal cluster analysis
a k-means clustering analysis you see
that you can the best of solution for
looking at those variables was this sort
of floor cluster solution that gave me
almost four equal groups you can see
that percentage is there I'm going to
try to get through these quickly because
so I do have some time for your
questions but you can see one of our
profiles I called to the high peer
support low parental support and just to
give you a quick how to like think about
these this is the the distribution this
is the 25th percentile the 75th
percentile and this line represents the
median for the entire sample this
represents where this particular cluster
falls so you can see that they fall a
little bit above the median but I'm
calling that average because it really
is sort of still within
at 25 to 75 percent window of what would
be considered you know the bulk of the
the distribution of scores for the
entire sample where they're a little bit
higher is impure appear social support
there about at the median for the CD RS
or this sort of coping proxy measure
that I'm using and they're a little bit
lower on parental support so this was
about twenty eight percent of my sample
I've got another group that's more low
peer and parental support but they are
at about the average levels for mastery
and that CD RS measure or stress and
coping measure but you can see quite
outside the bound for a peer support and
somewhat lower on the parental support
for the third one that I saw these are
the really the guys are doing really
great you could almost say these are
ones that are above average man's
mastery they've got you know pretty
strong peer support above average
resilience or stress and coping and
they've got way above average parental
support that's about 54 that's about 25
send a sample or 55 participants and
then the last profile is the ones these
are guys who are not doing so well these
are guys who have low self-efficacy very
low relative to the rest of the sample
very low stress coping relative to the
rest of the sample about middle range
for a peer in parental support but these
are guys that are defined by the low
mastery and and stress coping and that's
about twenty one percent of my sample so
what I did is look at those profiles are
relative to mental health outcomes using
the BSI the brief symptom inventory very
commonly used measure that gets that
multiple domains of mental health
functioning here I'm sorry this is the
k10 that's what I started with and I use
the BSI k10 you can see a pattern it
that's going to be the same for a lot of
my outcomes here the guys that are my
group that you know high mastery high
stress coping have the lowest these low
mastery low stress coping guys have the
highest when I look at somatization on
the BS I see a very similar pattern
these groups are not really differing
that much so even those the mo parental
support but high peer support group even
the low peer support the low parental
support group they're they're all you
know they're doing a little worse but
they're not that bad relative to these
guys and remember these groups are all
out there if you wanted to find them as
anything they all have at least average
levels of mastering coping relative to
these um won't continue like specifics
but obsessive-compulsive same pattern
anxiety same pattern hostility again
another sub scale of BS I same pattern
psychoticism st. pattern and what is
really important here is when I compare
those first three groups with the last
groups the effect sizes are huge like
bigger than I've seen in anything that
I've for my own data that I've collected
no point seven 22.98 when I look at
those mean differences for those lower
result or low slow mastery low stress
coping guys relative to the all the
other three that remember they did have
they differed on their support levels
whether that low parental support or low
peer support or both but they had you
know basically average levels if not
above of master Ian and stress and
coping and so one of the things that it
seemed what's going on here was that
these outcomes seemed most influenced by
mental or the mastery or self efficacy
measures and coping skills and that that
may be what is most important for us to
focus on in terms of these resilience
factors I just want to know that and
this is like my second to last slide
here but there's a lot that I think we
have to learn there's a lot more to
investigate when it comes to resilience
when it comes to how to best
operationalize and conceptualize it
but one of the things that I think is
really important and I think is
something that take us back to the first
sort of set of findings I told you about
is that there are still some issues and
pruning reasons because we are focusing
mostly on individual level phenomena
when we think about resilience it's
mostly operationalized in individual
level terms social support may be the
one way of thinking of it outside of
that framework but one thing I think we
have to be balanced about is not
promoting resilience at the cost of not
you know really doing the hard work of
developing and implementing structural
interventions that are going to change
social conditions and why is that so
important because when I and I couldn't
have a bullet for this but when I
started looking at those profiles as
potential buffers I didn't really see
much happening i saw a marginal effect
for moderation when I looked at mental
health outcomes but not really for the
HIV risk outcomes and I I have not done
the type of analysis to tell you that
it's those traumatic factors in these
sort of social conditions or factors
related to social conditions that are
most impactful but based on sort of my
inability to look at or find sort of
that buffering I am thinking that these
are still important and perhaps more
important factors to focus on in terms
of future work and interventions so I
will leave it there I actually I'll
leave it here with some campaigns and
messages that we've seen actually in New
York City that I think get at one thing
that's also undergirding a lot of this
and I haven't talked about but that's
stigma and sort of a lack of acceptance
for a lot of black MSM and so more
campaigns like this more focus on
changing policies that in person
conditions and programs that improve
conditions is really I think where we
need to next go for for this population
and just want to acknowledge that CDC
front of this work and it wouldn't it
happen without a number of research
assistants and collaborators so
you very much